now on problem 37 37 and they say what
is the value of XY minus y Z minus y Z
statement 1 says y is equal to 2 well
that by itself doesn't help us that just
tells us 2 X minus 2 Z so if you don't
know what x and z are you can't figure
out what this whole thing is if you just
know Y is equal to so that alone doesn't
help statement 2 is X minus Z is equal
to 5x minus Z is equal to 5 now this is
interesting because this expression we
can factor out the Y what happens if we
take if we divide if we factor out of Y
of these both of these expressions let
me just rewrite it XY minus zy I just
switched the Y in the Z that equals X
minus Z times y well we can figure out X
minus C from statement number 2 X minus
C this is equal to 5 and we know what Y
is equal from statement 1 so Y is equal
to 2 so we can definitely figure out as
long as we have both statements and we
can show that the answer is well Y is
equal to 2 so the answer is 2 times 5 is
10 but we didn't have to figure it out
we just had to know that we could figure
it out if we had both of these data
points 1 by themselves you you wouldn't
be able to solve it so the answer is C
both statements together are sufficient
but neither alone is problem 38 ok they
drew us a picture let me see if I can
draw that same picture looks like some
type of device so it looks like that and
they have the other end yes the other
end looks like that there's these
handles or something it looks like antal
haven't read the problem yet so they say
with the first 10 volumes of a 20 volume
encyclopedia fit up right in the book
rack shown above this is a book rack so
I guess the books get stacked that way
and they label this right here this
dimension is X
and they're saying we'll the first 10
volumes of a 20 volume encyclopedia fit
up right in the book rack shown above so
essentially I am I gonna put the first
ten in there so the first statement they
say is that X is equal to 50 centimeters
well that doesn't help me because I
don't know how big the first ten volumes
of the Encyclopedia are if each of them
are at least the first ten are less than
5 centimeters each are on average less
than 5 centimeters and I maybe I could
fit them but one by itself doesn't help
me to twelve of the volumes twelve of
the volumes have an average thickness of
five centimeters
twelve have average of five well that
doesn't help me either because remember
they're saying well the first 10 volumes
of a 20 volume encyclopedia may be the
twelve that have an average thickness of
five centimeters maybe those are the you
know volumes 8 through 20 and volume
maybe volumes 1 through 7 have an
average thickness of 50 centimeters each
or five million centimeters each so even
both of these conditions combined don't
help me know if I can definitely fit the
first ten volumes of the 20 volume
encyclopedia so that is e both
statements together are still not
sufficient problem 39
a circular tub okay so they've drawn
this circular looking tub so the top
looks like that and then there's two
sides you know well I can construct what
they've drawn and the bottom something
like that and then they shade in a
little area a strip of this like that
and they say a circular tub has a
painted band has a band painted around
its circumference is shown above so this
is the painted band around its
circumference what is the surface area
of the painted band and they tell us
that the height of the painted band is X
so in order to essentially know the
surface area you would have to know the
height which is X x times the
circumference of the circle right which
would be the length so if you knew the
height times the circumference of circle
you'll be able to know the surface area
so they tell us the first statement X is
equal to 0.5 0.5 whatever meters so this
is in meters 0.5 meters so that's that
alone doesn't help us we have to be able
to figure out the circumference of this
tub in order to really be able to figure
out the surface area because the
circumference times its height will be
the surface area point - they say the
height of the tub is 1 meter so they are
telling us that this is 1 meter well
that doesn't help us that still doesn't
tell us how far around to the tub goes
if they had given us the diameter or the
radius or the circumference then we
could have used our basic geometry to
figure out the circumference but they
didn't so either way so one meter height
both of these combined still do not
allow us to figure out the surface area
of this green band II again problem 40
what is the value of integer N and n is
an integer so statement number one they
tell us that n times n plus 1 is equal
to 6
now I we should already be able to
figure this out because n is an integer
and
one is an integer so let's just so what
are the the factorizations of six you
could have one times six
but that doesn't fit n in n plus one
right this is N and n plus five you have
two times three which work right if two
is n n plus one is three and they equals
six let me circle that and then what
other factorizations you don't have any
other four times so these are these are
all of the factors of six and so just
looking at the first statement you know
that n has to be equal to two this is
the only integer where this is true
actually let me let me take that let me
take a step back no what if n is
negative because I was assuming it's a
positive integer but they didn't say
it's a positive integer so let me think
about that if I did minus 3 times minus
2 that also equals 6 and these are both
integers huh
ok so this isn't enough because in this
case and could because this would be N
and this would be n plus 1 so n is
either equal to 2 or n is equal to minus
3 that's a little tricky yet the
intuition is to just assume that n is
positive but it doesn't have to be
positive so n could be 2 or minus 3 here
that's a tricky one so that one by
itself does not help us solve the
problem the second part of it
point to it says 2 to the 2n is equal to
16 and whenever you have these and
whether you're doing the SAT or the GMAT
or anything whenever you have a variable
in the exponent your goal really is to
just get everything in the same base so
we could write the left-hand side the
same so that's 2 to the 2n and how do we
write 16 as a as a with the base 2 well
16 is just 2 to the fourth right 2 to
the fourth and so we get 2 n is equal to
4 n is equal to 2 so this this statement
alone is enough to figure it out this
statement alone is not so the answer is
B our review for what the state
B statement two alone is sufficient
already is B and this was tricky because
one you you think that one is aloneness
efficient but it is ambiguous because n
could be -3 41 41 okay they've drawn a
bunch of if I see this right they've
drawn a bunch two lines I can draw this
so line and then they have a bunch of
circles one circle two circles they have
and then they keep going see three
circles and then one more like right
there or a circles I think that's about
right and then they keep they say
essentially that the circles just keep
going on and on that's what I think the
drawing implies and they say the inside
of a rectangular carton is 48
centimeters long so the inside of a
rectangular carton is 48 centimeters
long 32 centimeters wide so 32
centimeters wide this is an 8 32
centimeters wide and 15 centimeters high
15 centimeters high okay so that's the
inside kind of reviewing from the other
from the other wall this is the floor of
the inside of the container and then
there would be another up here but I
think you get the idea the carton is
filled to capacity with K identical
cylindrical cans of fruit that stand up
rights in rows and columns as indicated
in the figure above okay so this is like
a top view of it so you can we could say
that this side up here this is the top
this is 48 and then this is 32 so we
don't care so much about the height I
think so let's see the carton is full to
capacity with K identical cylindrical
cans are furthest and upright in rows
and columns indicate in the figure above
if the
hands are 15 centimeters high okay so
each of the cans are exactly 15
centimeters high so they're they
literally are as exactly high as the
carton if the cans are 15 centimeters
high what is the value of K so we have
to figure out how many will fit how many
of these cans will fit in this in this
area essentially and they tell us point
number one each of the cans have a
radius of 4 centimeters radius is 4
centimeters well if we know that each of
them have a radius of 4 centimeters then
we know exactly how much Square area
each of these circles will take up
assuming that they're packed exactly
like this right because if you think
about it what is this area right here
well this is well there's a bunch of
different ways you could think about it
well the easiest is that if the radius
is 4 centimeters the diameter right here
is 8 centimeters so if this is 8 and you
have a 48 length you can only do six of
these all right 6 times 8 is 48 so you
can only do 6 that way and then if the
diameter is 8 this way and this length
is 32 you can only do four this way so
statement number one alone is enough to
figure out how many you can put it would
actually be 4 times 6 you could put 24 K
would be 24 cans and you could fit in so
statement 1 alone is enough now what a
statement to tell us 6 of the cans fit
exactly along the length of the carton 6
of the cans fit exactly along the length
of the carton so they're telling us that
these cans that there's 6 cans that fit
right along the length which we figured
out from statement number 1 but that
also gives you the same information as
statement number 1 because you know that
these are cylindrical cans I guess we
can assume I think it's a safe
assumption to say that these are that
these are circles although they haven't
you know a cylinder yeah a cylinder
you're assuming that the tops are
circles so if you say that six can fit
that way then you know that the diameter
of each of them is 8 centimeters and
then you can make the same argument to
the diameter is 8 centimeters to say
that 4 can fit the other way down so 2
alone is also 2 also is sufficient by
itself
so the answer is what is that see both
statements no no D each statement alone
is sufficient see in the next video